I need your help so I'm writing a book
about one word and I've talked about one
word a lot basically I believe that
everybody has one word that defines them
defines who they are and when you
understand what your one word is what
your core is it makes it so much easier
to make every decision better easier in
your life and in your business some
people see that message they love it
they apply it immediately they see great
results others are skeptical to think ah
it's just a motivating thing it this
isn't going to take off this isn't for
me for me believe isn't just a
motivating thing it should motivate you
because your one word should be
inspiring to get you awake in the
morning should get you excited to start
your day but it helps make me understand
and make decisions for everything I do
my business in my life so if I'm
creating a social media campaign it's
got to be able to believe if I am
bringing on a new person on my team they
have to be about believe if I'm
launching a program with a new client
they have to be about belief so believe
is the core of everything that I do and
all my decisions filter through that and
if it's believed related then I can
continue with it it was not then it's
the wrong client or it's a wrong
campaign or it's the wrong employee and
so I want to encourage entrepreneurs to
find their own one word and then use
that to apply to make every decision in
their business and life easier so I have
a few examples that I'm writing about in
my book we've got three M where
innovation is there one word and you
know you have to be innovative to work
at 3m if you're not innovative then
you're not going to have fun there
you're not going to be successful there
you're not going to have a great career
there there's Jessica Alba who's
launched the honest company and so
honesty is her one word if you are not
honest you're not going to have a great
time working with jessica alba you know
your your your business won't last long
working with her you won't last long as
an employee working with her and her
marketing has to be about honesty what
I'm looking for is more examples and
ideally bigger-name examples people who
you look at and you can say yeah I know
who that person is I've got a lot of
great smaller
entrepreneur examples which I'm going to
share too but I'm looking for kind of
the bigger name people who have done
this and so I need your help if you guys
know of any successful kind of
name-brand person who's used this in
their business or their life and not
just like a marketing slogan you know
coca-cola may come up with a marketing
slogan for one year that's that's one
word but then the next year change the
next year change I'm not looking for
that I'm not looking for just a
marketing thing this is the core of
everything is the corp how you define
your life and then live through that one
word and so if you guys have any
examples if you're researching or coming
across any stories that you think would
apply please let me know leave it in the
comments message me whatever else works
the way to reach out to me I'm pretty
accessible let me know I really want
this book to help start a revolution and
really help people live their life on
purpose instead of walking aimlessly
through it and I would love to have you
be a part of it so let me know if you
can help share some ideas I'd love to
hear from you believe thank you guys so
much I'm looking forward to your
comments don't forget to subscribe to
the channel click on my face and I will
see you soon